I just noticed this in the commercial
break Andy is that an Apple watch yeah
yeah I am look look at that yeah yeah
watch they sent me one early cuz they
wanted me to wear it on the show it's
pretty cool right yeah sure I guess so
yeah I can get text messages on it I
mean I don't I couldn't even tell me how
many steps I've taken today for that's
cool you know it's funny it just seems
like to me it seems like a lot of
technology for a watch you know it's a
watch not at all I mean it's great
alright ok well tell me what time it is
this is cool because I don't have to
look at it I have to do is just lift my
arm what's supposed to tell me it should
do it automatically I'm going straight
ahead I must be doing something it's a
watch it shouldn't be this hard to find
out what time it is
Oh oh no I closed down the time app and
just need to reopen it wait there's an
app to tell time you know what it just
froze up I got I got to restart it
restart it
[Applause]
it's gotta give it whoa whoa come on
Andy let's go come on it froze again
okay what so okay just you know it's
spinning so we'll just uh see just see
Game of Thrones on Sunday no I didn't I
didn't see it yet I wasn't I was intense
dragons are so cool and and then there
was like that
prance or Duke or whatever you are just
stalling I want to know what time Oh its
back its back okay great
what time is it I found four recipes for
lime biscuit no sirree must have heard
you know Siri what is the time of day
playing more stay and at the time no no
no sirree Siri tell me the time T IME
calling 10 e hello look I'm sorry to
bother you do you know what time it is
are you one of those Apple watch
leave me alone hey Andy just
forget it I don't care what time it
isn't you know look apple doesn't make
mistakes it's probably my fault I just
need to I'm gonna call customer support
I just don't know maybe all of the
details right fine thank you for calling
Apple if you recently purchased a new
MacBook and are wondering what happened
to all the holes for the cords press 1
if your iPhone feels really really hot
inside your pocket and you're wondering
what that's doing to your genitals press
just an Apple watch and want to know
what time it is press three okay I see
you want to know what time it is
great you are the 15th caller in line to
expedite your solutions simply visit our
headquarters in Cupertino California
where an apple watch time genius will
personally assist you Andy just give it
up give it up look I'm so close I can
actually I can find flights to Cupertino
on the Apple watch I'll just do that
Siri tell me flight times to Cupertino
okay finding words that might rhyme with
Filipino no you know why I love Pina it
maraschino
[Applause]
[Music]
you